Sorry this video took so long -- I had never actually seen the Child's Play movies before,
so I went ahead and binged them so that I
could properly analyse the trailer for you,
and I'm now kind of realizing I probably didn't
have to, but I did notice some interesting
stuff in the trailer and the website setup
for the fictional company within the movie,
so stick around to the end of this video if
you want to hear about it.
The beginning of the  Child's Play trailer plays as a commercial
for this company Kaslan, a tech company that
makes coffee machines, robotic vacuum cleaners,
tablets, VR games, robots, and toys.
If it's been a while since you watched the
original series, the company behind that was
called Play Pals Toys, so this is not the same
company.
All signs point to this being a re-imagining
of the original, so if the original had taken
place in the 10s or whatever the **** this
decade is called, it this is how it
might have gone down.
So the Good Guy dolls from the 1980s film
are now called Buddi, because for some reason
lower case 'i's are really popular this millenium,
I should probably just change my channel name
to be spelled like this.
Here's our new Andy Barclay, and in background
there's a photo of him and his father.
In the original Child's Play Andy does have
a deceased father, but we never really know
anything about him.
When we first see Andy it appears that he's
rocking some wireless headphones, however,
there's another shot later in the trailer
where it's evident that it's just his left
ear, and every time we see the left ear, it
has this device, which has to be his hearing
aid, because those are popular in horror movies now?
But in this movie, the hearing aid could be
subject to wireless interference from Chucky,
as a new 21st century way for Chucky to attack
Andy.
In fact, you can actually go to the website
on the side of the box, bestbuddi.com, where
there are more clues about Chucky's capabilities.
It's emphasized in the logo, which contains
the wifi symbol, telling us that internet
connectivity play a big part in this new doll,
and it will connect with tablets, computers
and cell phones.
Chucky is going to be connected to this Kaslan
ecosystem of smart devices, and I think the
horror in this movie is going to be a commentary
about how smart home devices are becoming
something we trust and rely on too much.
Look at this text: Your new best friend connects
to and controls all your Kaslan products and
smart home devices.
Not "you control your doll and your devices."
The doll is the one controlling the devices.
This company is in control of your home and
your life.
Look at this picture.
Chucky has control over your computer, your
fans, and your sound system, which I'm sure
ties right back into the fact that Andy has
a hearing aid.
He's also seen manipulating a smart TV, and
a drone, which brings to mind the scene from
Child's Play 3, where the CEO is attacked
by all the toys in his home, including an
RC helicopter.
This website also suggests that Buddi uses
AI to interpret human behaviour, which makes
me think that instead of the Chucky doll being
possessed by voodoo, like it is in the original,
the doll will be "possessed" by hackers, who
load a malicious code into the Buddi doll.
Maybe Charles Lee Ray is actually a cyber-criminal
in this movie.
The last item of note on this website is the
fact that Buddi comes loaded with the ability
to communicate in English and Spanish.
Andy's mother is played by actress Aubrey
Plaza in this movie, who has a Puerto Rican
background, so her and her son aren't going
to be safe from eavesdropping by Chucky no
matter which language they are speaking.
Let's talk about possible Easter Eggs.
The warehouse of Buddi dolls bears great resemblance
to the Good Guy doll storage in the factory
at the end of Child's Play 2.
The crime scene shows a covered body surrounded
by broken glass as if someone had fallen from
a window, which calls back to the original
Child's Play where Aunt Maggie becomes the
first victim of Chucky, at least in his doll
form.
This might be the fall actually happening,
and you may notice the Kaslan logo on the
truck in the background, meaning this accident
could have taken place at the factory or a
distributor.
Whatever is going on here bring reminders
of Andy and Kyle in the factory scene from
Child's Play 2, and when Chucky initially
grabs the clothes, I noticed a drill on the
table, which is one of the weapons used in
Cult of Chucky.
The movie will take place in the winter around
Christmas time like the original, although
it does not seem like they stuck with Chicago
for the setting unfortunately.
I don't recognize this license plate, but
it's most similar to Idaho or a South Dakota
alternate.
One thing I personally found interesting was the fact
that when Andy first unwraps the doll, we're
seeing from Chucky's point of view, as if
he's already on and gathering information
before they even open the box.
Now you may remember in the first movie, Chucky
had to go back to find Andy Barclay and take
over his body because he was the first one
Chucky revealed himself to.
"You have to transfer your soul out of the
doll, into that of the first human being you
revealed your true self to."
So maybe in the new movie Chucky is programmed
to go after the owner of the doll, and the
facial recognition determines who that actually
is.
Chucky is shown to be wielding his classic
knife in this movie...
"A true classic never goes out of style."
But there are some new modern weapons showcased
in this trailer, like the ability to turn
off the lights and give a new meaning to 'Black
Friday Shopping', and maybe even taking control
of a self driving car developed by Kaslan.
At the end of the trailer, you're prompted
to click on this next video, which is a special
announcement video from the Kaslan Corporation,
which you may or may not have already noticed
that the logo contains a blue eye, just like
that of Chucky.
The announcement features Henry Kaslan, the
founder of the Kaslan Corporation, and he
gives an introduction to the Buddi doll, saying
that every child deserves a companion.
The video description confirms that Buddi
will use artificial intelligence and encourages
viewers to visit KaslanCorp.com . Visiting
the site reveals more information about the
company and their technology, like the use
of HD cameras, and a paragraph about other
sensors.
It says, "Kaslan HUB and VR products come
equipped with state of the art haptic and
accelerator technology, to help you thrive
in the real world while also immersing you
in the in the imagination of the vast and
ever-evolving virtual reality landscape."
This means that Chucky's ability to hunt down
Andy has received a major upgrade, he'll have
the ability to learn the tendencies of Andy's
body movement to help him predict what his
victim is going to do before he even does
it.
There's also a products page where we can
take a closer look at some of the other Kaslan
products, like their drone who looks like
a flying shark and can fly 100 mph and track
it's victims using advanced algorithms to
track a subject as it flies up to 10,000 feet
overhead.
If this thing is tracking you, you're never
going to be safe.
There's also the vacuum that we saw in the
trailer, it's hard to imagine that being a
threat to man, but you never know.
The Kaslan K-One speakers have the capability
to track your movements to ensure location
focused personalized sound reproductions,
and this is what I think Chucky is going to
use to try to blast out Andy's hearing aid.
Finally we have the Kaslan HUB, which is likely
a parody of the Google Home Hub from real
life, and this is the central brain that controls
all the Kaslan products throughout the house
which can be used by the touch screen or voice
operated, and if you look at the trailer,
the Barclays actually do have this in their
home.
At the bottom of the site you can enter your
email to get updates, so if there are any
update emails or updates to the website or
ARG in general, I'll be sure to make a video
to keep you up to date on any supplemental
world building for this movie.
So if you want to stay up to date, remember
to subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every
week, ring that deathbell for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming, we both survive.